institute there
a pioneer in algorithms and and game
theory
and
microeconomics
um
has a whole string of awards a murray
grace hopper award collide prize girdle
prize invited icm speaker
guggenheim fellow very pleased to have
tim here telling us about
a case study in blockchains and web3
welcome time
just to echo some of the things other
speakers have said today um it's a real
privilege participating in the in the
10th anniversary for the simons
institute um happy birthday simons
institute
um it's really you know added a
completely new dimension i think to
being a theoretic theoretical computer
scientist um i was lucky enough to be
you know sort of within spitting
distance of the institute for a number
of the last 10 years it certainly had a
huge influence on my life uh really
enjoyed sort of um engaging with it um
you know
and i just want to you know for the
students in the audience just for some
perspective like if you ever have the
feeling you know you're reading some
paper from like 20 years ago you're like
oh my god i can't believe how easy the
theorems were 20 years ago i was born
too late i missed the golden age
i'm here to tell you there's a lot of
older people in this room that feel like
we were born too early and didn't get to
enjoy the simon's institute until fairly
late in our career and so we are in one
of the golden ages of theoretical
computer science and the simons
institute is a big reason for why okay
um i want to talk a little bit about
blockchains and the applications that
are being built on top of them which is
sometimes collectively referred to
as web3 goals are pretty modest i really
just want to convince you that there's
some super interesting computer science
that goes into this technology
and you know i'm biased as a
theoretician but i believe whenever you
see super interesting computer science
you can usually bet that theory is
playing a very fundamental role and
that's absolutely true in this
application domain if you know how to
look for its print fingerprints you see
it everywhere okay and so i want to give
you a glimpse of that uh today okay
but um first so i have to say like in my
25 year career as a computer scientist
never have i seen a technology so like
widely and deeply misunderstood as
blockchains and their applications
i think in part it's it's sort of a
testament to the power of first
impressions so bitcoin rolled out around
2008-2009
and a lot of viewpoints a lot of sort of
narratives got very hardened very
quickly uh in those early days
and while i think some of those
viewpoints were maybe kind of at least
semi-valid you know eight to ten years
ago um since then there's been many new
generations of blockchain protocols are
thinking uh the evolution and our
thinking of what they can accomplish has
changed a lot
um and so really what i want to do is
just take an honest look at this
technology
in 2022
and not through the lens of you know
investment or money or politics but
really just through the lens of computer
science and specifically theoretical
science
so in that spirit let me just give you
one slide you know this is how i
recommend this is what i would suggest
as a mental model for how to think about
a blockchain and i'm really thinking
about blockchains here almost informally
but almost like a computational model
like what computing functionality does
this give us that we didn't already have
before and now just a couple caveats
like what i write on the slide i'm not
going to claim it's literally true or
even really like well-defined in a
mathematical sense
but i do claim it's sort of a good
mental model for thinking about what
this technology might be good for and
the technical challenges that will come
up when you when you try to build it
okay
so what's a blockchain really and so
here i'm talking about general purpose
smart contract platform so if something
like ethereum would be the the biggest
and best uh known example of there's
many generations since then as well
um
it's a computer
the way that your laptop is a computer
okay now like a physical computer the
way your laptop is but rather the
product of sort of a simulation of a
virtual machine okay carried out by lots
of nodes scattered across the internet i
like to think of it as like just kind of
a big computer that lives in the sky
operating in public view
running basically as a as a public good
all right so so what you all have
computers on your on your wrists and in
your pocket plus viewed as a computer
blockchains are about as powerful as
computers were literally like 50 years
ago so there better be more to the story
and there is
so it's a very unusual computer in that
in effect it has no owner uh or operator
we'll talk exactly what this means i'm
in the second technical section but you
should think of it that there's no one
who really has control over this
computer runs on its own for example no
one's in a position to to shut it down
it's open access in the sense that
anybody can use it there might be you
know a usage fee especially if there's
congestion
but you don't have to you don't need to
be on any whitelist you don't need to
register anywhere you can just use this
computer by use i mean either sort of
interact with existing software meaning
smart contracts or install new software
if you prefer
and finally
and maybe most interestingly is the is
the paradox that despite the fact that
this computer in the sky
effectively has no owner
it nonetheless enables a notion of
ownership for its users okay so if
you're an end user of a blockchain like
say ethereum you can own data that lives
on that computer in a meaningful sense
and that computer in the sky will
enforce property rights for digital data
on your behalf and i use the phrase
property rights in the totally
traditional sense of the term okay the
way we're familiar with physical
possessions right right to use right to
transfer right to exclude etc okay so
this paradox uh seemingly uh of having
an ownerless computer that through
cryptography enables
verifiable ownership meaningful
ownership for data stored on it that is
really the fundamental problem that
nakamoto figured out with the bitcoin
protocol in my opinion nakamoto had in
mind the very specific use case where
what the digital data represented was a
currency was bitcoins but that is not
fundamental to the technology okay it's
really just enforcing property rights
for digital data okay
so um i don't know how you would get
this combination of properties before
the advent of blockchain technologies
which makes it a logical possibility
certainly not a foregone conclusion but
a logical possibility that this new
computing functionality might enable
sort of truly game-changing applications
applications that change the life of a
randomly sampled person on the planet
the way i think most of us would agree
that the internet has
at this point okay and if so for those
app for that to happen
the application layer has to figure out
exactly how to use this unique
combination of properties that this
computational model gives us okay
something on everybody's mind just like
okay so like but what are those
applications going to be you know like
what's going to be the the truly sort of
killer app of having a sort of
enforceable ownership for digital data
um and it's not like there aren't any
answers to that question there are but
it's i think it's a little it's been 13
years since the bitcoin protocol rolled
out um since we had blockchains 13 years
after the internet rolled out that was
that was 1983. if you'd asked anybody
what were the killer applications of the
internet in 1983 you would have gotten
answers that did not resemble whatsoever
what we think about today it's not to
say there weren't any answers you could
send email you could transfer files
but it's just the really game-changing
applications were still years in the
future and i would predict that the same
kind of pattern is going to is going to
recur with with blockchains in web3
okay so under the technical part of the
talk which i've optimized for breath
over depth so i want to talk about three
different topics
and i've deliberately chosen them so
that they illustrate how totally
different parts of theoretical computer
science show up in this application
domain we're going to talk about
algorithmic mechanism design we're going
to talk about distributed computing and
we're going to talk about proof systems
obviously i won't have time to talk much
about any of these but i hope it gives
you a glimpse of all the different ways
that theory is kind of you know playing
an important role in this in this
application domain
all right so i want to start with this
idea that the computer in the sky is
open access that anybody can use it
so the question is how do we how do we
make that actually economically viable
so
because here's the thing right i said
that the computer in the sky is about as
powerful as computers from the 1970s
right so as you probably know
blockchains fundamentally they maintain
an ordered sequence of transactions you
can think of that as a payment if you
like or i encourage you to think of it
actually as sort of a line of a program
being executed in some virtual machine
in any case a blockchain
has a maintains a sequence of
instructions
and those are added to the blockchain in
batches known as blocks and those blocks
only come along every so often and
they're only so big
using ethereum as an example you expect
to see one new batch of transactions
every 13 seconds or so a typical batch
might have something like 200
transactions in it so we're talking
about something like processing 15
transactions per second which maybe
sounds like not that much and it's not
that much that's what i meant by saying
it was like a 1970 style computer
so what that means is that if you have a
blockchain that's that's really quite
popular the way ethereum is it means
demand for the scarce resource of that
blockchain's virtual machine computation
on that blockchain that's going to be a
scarce resource okay demand will be much
much bigger than supply
so no matter how altruistic you are just
the blockchain is going to have to
figure out which transactions to
actually execute in its virtual machine
and which ones to exclude there's no
choice but to make uh that decision so
the transaction fee mechanism is the
part of a blockchain that makes that
decision
if you want to take seriously the idea
this computer is a public good
we should be allocating that scarce
resource in the most valuable way
possible that is to the transactions
that would benefit most from inclusion
so that's the job of this mechanism to
figure out which of the transactions
that are the the most valuable
so let me tell you how this works in
bitcoin
and how it worked in ethereum until
about nine months ago something called a
first price auction and it's
supernatural
you can't expect the blockchain to know
which transactions are the valuable ones
so you ask users to submit to basically
tell you how valuable their transactions
are to them
now you need to make them put their
money where their mouth is so they
actually have to attach a bid to a
transaction which is then going to be
paid
should that transaction ever be included
on the blockchain into one of these
blocks okay
now you might have a question like okay
but to whom like i thought this computer
had no owner or operator so who exactly
is the user paying for to have their
transaction executed
well so let me to answer that let me
unpack a little bit more about how these
things work okay so um you know we
talked about um so okay so what does it
mean to be ownerless
so really what i mean by ownerless is
that there's thousands hopefully of
different physical machines uh sort of
collaborating through a consensus
protocol to have a virtual simulation um
of a virtual machine so they're
responsible for coordinating with each
other to keep track of this running log
of transactions i also said how new
batches of transactions are added to
that log one at a time and so how does
that happen
well while all of the nodes collectively
maintain the past
one node gets to unilaterally decide the
next block of the future okay so each
batch of transactions is going to be
added by one single node not a
cooperation for all of them there will
be a unilateral dictator for each batch
of transactions that'll be very
important for us for for our mechanism
design problem okay
so now it's clear who the bid should be
transferred to right so if your
transaction winds up being included on
this blockchain if it gets executed in
the virtual machine there is one
specific node who was responsible for it
getting included so that's the natural
recipient
of your bid okay so that's the first
price auction you have end users
submitting track transactions they want
to be executed by the blockchain if
executed they pay the bid where's the
bid go to whichever uh block producer
included that transaction in the in the
batch that they added
okay now if you know a little auction
theory little mechanism design
you know the first price auctions are
pretty natural but they also have some
issues and in particular it can be very
hard to reason about how to bid in first
price auctions we've known this for 50
years okay being in the blockchain
setting doesn't make it any easier
because basically you want to get away
with like the smallest bid possible but
subject to actually being included
and the smallest bid you can get away
with sort of depends on what your
competitors are bidding so you have to
then sort of reason about your
competitors bids okay and that's sort of
a burdensome computation to require
auction participants to do if you've
ever heard of something like a second
price auction or the vcg mechanism those
are completely different there you all
you have to do is figure out your
maximum willingness to pay you report
that to the mechanism and you're
guaranteed that's going to be your
optimal strategy so way way easier to
participate in second price type
auctions than first price type ones
and so an obvious question uh we could
take this seriously as a mechanism
design problem and ask is there a better
transaction mechanism than the one that
has been in use
for example could there be a truthful
mechanism in the spirit
of the vcg mechanism okay so that's the
subject of this of this first
technical part and one of the things
actually that's very fun about about
talking about this topic um so first of
all one really neat thing that's going
to happen is that blockchains are going
to produce some they're going to have
some unusual idiosyncrasies which will
force us to take what would seem to be a
well-solved mechanism design problem and
really reconsider it from first
principles that's the first thing that's
going to happen
the second really fun thing is that
because this technology is so early this
is an application of mechanism design at
a really unusually low layer of the
stack right like if you think about the
internet right
lots of opportunities for people who do
mechanism design at the application
layer right designing you know i don't
know some two-sided you know platform
for example on the on the application
layer of the internet
this is more like doing mechanism design
for like bgp routing or tcp congestion
control this is really in the plumbing
of blockchain technologies obviously
there's more applications for mechanism
design sort of on top on the application
layer but this is really down in the
guts okay and so this is something we
never saw with the internet we never we
never saw mechanism design thinking uh
really influence the key internet
protocols but we are seeing it influence
sort of uh fundamental blockchain
technologies
so i hope this seems like a reasonably
natural question to you right so
blockchains have to figure out what gets
in what stays out we need the mechanism
to do that why not seek out the best
mechanism in some sense i'm at the time
that i did this work which is sort of
late 2020 it was also a super timely
question specifically for the ethereum
blockchain
because at that time they were
contemplating making a big change to
their transaction fee mechanism i'll
tell you about that change um in a
second
so it was a mechanism proposed in the
ethereum improvement proposal eip
numbered 1559
and it was very controversial we can
talk in the q a why it was controversial
if you like but it was controversial
some people really liked it some people
either hated it or it best didn't
understand it
so so this is a survey that was run by
tim baiko again this was late 2020 so he
reached out he was sort of he's a key
member in the ethereum community he
reached out to lots of stakeholders you
know people who sort of design software
wallets people who are block producers
people who runs exchanges and asked
everybody
do you think we should switch our
transaction mechanism to this new one
into this new more complicated one
and if not why not and is there anything
we could do to make you more comfortable
with the prospect of sort of this change
and people raise various things but what
i want to highlight what i want to
highlight here is quote the lack of a
formal specification or proof for the
mechanism for people to independently
evaluate and critique
and i want to emphasize not a single
respondent to this survey is someone who
writes academic research papers these
are all people who build who build
things in the ethereum trenches and yet
there is a visceral hunger from this
community for what we do okay for
theoretical computer science that was
like the missing piece for getting sort
of sufficient support about this big
change to the ethereum blockchain okay
so there's no question that was a big
motivation for why i went and did this
work
oh sweet there's water
so what's idiosyncratic about the
blockchain setting why do we have to
rethink mechanism design problems from
first principles
we have the usual issue you have an
auction design that you have to worry
about people misrepresenting their
preferences like bidding sort of
artificially trying to shade their bid
in the first price auction we have
standard language for saying we would
like mechanisms robust to this kind of
sort of gaming uh it's a truthful
mechanism or a or a dc mechanism okay
this is the usual challenge that's why i
labeled the challenge zero challenge
ones one through three are really
specific to the blockchain setup
so first of all i made a big deal in
emphasizing that when a new batch of
transactions gets added to the
blockchain there is one node that is
selected to have unilateral control over
the contents of that block okay
and so what that means is when you're
designing a mechanism right you can from
your orange armchair write down a design
that you would really like these nodes
to carry out
but ultimately they can do whatever they
want okay the node selected at random to
produce the next batch can run in some
sense whatever transaction mechanism it
pleases okay so the second incentive
compatibility compatibility guarantee
we're going to need which again this
this one is new
is that we're also in a mechanism that
should not just be robust to to the
participants in the auction but also to
the party tasked with carrying out the
auction so the auctioneer or whoever is
carrying out the mechanism is not a
trusted party it's a profit maximizing
block producer and our mechanism should
respect that fact so mmic is going to
state
that it should be in the block
producer's best interest if it wants to
just maximize its own revenue should be
in its own best interest to actually
carry forth the the transaction fee
mechanism that you're proposing okay
also um the block producer in addition
to sort of excluding or including
whatever it wants it can basically
costlessly inject its own fake
transactions and the reason you never
hear about a second price auction of the
vcg mechanism in a blockchain setting is
this okay it's because second price
auctions are really easy to manipulate
uh if you get to sort of see all of the
bids and then after the fact inject a
shill bid of your own it basically
devolves into a first price auction okay
so our first new incentive compatibility
constraint says block producers should
be motivated to carry out the mechanism
you write down
uh and then the last thing i want to
highlight something i call oca proofness
oca here is for is for off-chain
agreement so we've already talked about
robustness to manipulations by users and
by block producers this third one is
about manipulations by uh cartels of
block producers with users okay those
this this is very easy to carry out in a
blockchain context through for example
smart contract smart contract
functionality you also don't have the
legal channels familiar from the real
world the one often uses to sort of deal
with collusion so here you know you
usually punt on collusion in sort of
traditional applications of mechanism
design you cannot afford to do that in a
blockchain setting you need to design a
mechanism that really the mechanism
itself makes it unprofitable for cartels
to manipulate manipulate your mechanism
so the technical question then is going
to be we have three incentive
compatibility guarantees on the slide
right corresponding to robustness to
manipulations by users or block
producers or cartels of both the
question is does there does there not
exist a transaction mechanism that
satisfies all three simultaneously okay
so let me tell you about the the
mechanism that ethereum wanted to switch
to okay and then we can assess how well
it does on those three incentive
compatibility criteria that i just laid
out okay
three big ideas in this first big idea
is a reserve price okay
uh which is a standard thing you do in
auction theory interestingly if you use
a reserve price in the most obvious way
okay meaning transferring revenues
generated by the reserve price onto the
block producer the person responsible
for that block
actually the game theory goes haywire
and you lose that oca proofness property
that i talked about reserve prices of
that form can be evaded by cartels of
users and block producers
as a consequence this transaction
mechanism to something quite
non-standard which is it takes all of
the revenues all of the payments of the
reserve price and burns them i burn them
i mean literally removes those coins
from circulation forever okay so they're
paid by the end users they go to nobody
all right that fixes the game theory
that's going to restore the oca
proofness property
second big idea is you know to figure
out okay so what should this reserve
price be okay and a natural idea is to
use local search if the price looks too
low raise it up a little bit the price
looks too high bring it down a little
bit
how do you know okay from what's
happened in the past whether your
current price is too high or too low
and so here the idea is to use variable
size blocks historically ethereum
ethereum had a hard cap on block size
like 200 transactions per block
and with this change they said you know
what let's just make that kind of a soft
constraint let's have a target of 200
transactions per block but allow it to
be more or less okay you still need some
kind of hard cap for technical reasons
so let's say you could go up to 400
transactions if you want but we're
really targeting 200 transactions per
block
now you have just publicly available
information which tells you exactly how
to run your local search algorithm if
the last block was too big that means
your price is too low you should raise
it if the last block was too small like
only 150 transactions that suggest your
current reserve price is too high not
enough people are willing to pay it so
you should decrease it okay so you use
the pattern of blocks and whether
they're above or below your target to do
the adjustment process on the reserve
price
the third maybe least important property
for our purposes is sort of an emergency
backup first price auction which is part
of the mechanism
so users have the option to paying above
and beyond the reserve price if they
want something known as a tip and then
that tip gets transferred to the
producer of the block just like bids did
historically
in first price auctions okay so that's
the new transaction fee mechanism that
was being contemplated basically
congestion pricing using block sizes to
figure out how to adjust uh adjust the
reserve price with the reserve price
necessarily being burned for the game
theory to work okay
so we've got our three incentive
compatibility guarantees so we can
formally assess this proposed mechanism
how well does it do um and you know
i don't know that i'd give it an a plus
but i would definitely give it an a okay
it scores it's a pareto improvement over
first price auctions first price
auctions satisfy the the mmic and oca
proofness guarantees i'm pretty easy to
see
as we discussed they're really not
truthful at all
this new transaction fee mechanism
satisfies the same two properties the
two new incentive compatibility
guarantees
and is also in some sense usually
truthful okay it usually acts like a
posted price mechanism which is a
truthful mechanism except in one
particular edge case okay the edge case
being when you've just had a very long
period of low stable command demand and
you have a sudden demand spike meaning
that you would like to sort of instantly
have a much higher reserve price
but the mechanism is going to sort of
gradually increase the reserve price so
there'll be this period of like a few
minutes where it acts more it sort of
reverts gracefully back to a first price
auction okay so the theorem says that's
the only edge case there's this obvious
scenario in which truthfulness fails
unless you're in the obvious scenario
actually you have you have the decent
guarantee that that you want it
um i also proposed a sort of an
alternative uh mechanism which moves
that usually in front of the seconds
guarantee so always mmic always truthful
usually oca proof with the exact same
edge case um and actually there's a
really nice paper out of carnegie mellon
how chung and elaine she who show that
actually you need that usually okay
there's actually an impossibility
theorem now saying you cannot get all
three of these incentive compatibility
guarantees uh simultaneously okay so you
need to make the small compromises
either in eip1559
or in the tipless variant
and then i guess just to finish that
story you know nine months ago ethereum
did in fact switch to using eip1559 um
and it's been humming along ever since
all right so next technical part i want
to remember the computer in the sky i
said it was ownerless right so what do i
mean right so i mean there's thousands
of physical machines running a consensus
protocol keeping in sync about the
current state of the virtual machine
okay that that blockchain represents
right
so we should talk about consensus
totally classic topic and theoretical
computer science right couple turning
awards have been giving out to lamport
and liskov um fundamental work in the
1980s 1990s and since then as well
which right it's kind of amazing right
so so obviously in the 1980s researchers
working on consensus were not thinking
about blockchains blockchains were not a
gleam in anyone's eye and yet as we see
so often over and over again in theory
right if you get the abstractions right
if you get the definitions right they're
going to be exactly what you need 40
years later for some application you
never could have anticipated and there's
yet another example of that that
phenomenon
now so they identified the consensus
problem but they were working in what we
would now call a permissioned consensus
setting
what does that mean that means when you
fire up your consensus protocol so
you've got a bunch of physical machines
all running copies of a piece of
software permissioned means you know all
of those machines up front okay so for
example you know maybe ibm you know
wants to replicate a database get really
high up time so by seven computers puts
them all over the world so it can
tolerate two failures and still stay and
stick okay
permissioned assumption totally
reasonable for those 1980s style
applications
the vision for blockchains the reason
blockchains do consensus is different
okay it's not really for replica it has
the effect of replication of sort of
better uptime but it's really for this
ownerless property right that's really
what you're after
and so accordingly the vision's a bit
different
any of you right after this talk you
could go to your laptop you could
download software for the bitcoin
protocol you could start running it your
computer would literally be one of those
physical nodes contributing to the
consensus protocol that drives for
example the bitcoin protocol okay so
this is completely different than the
permission setting you have no idea you
know now or ever who exactly is going to
be running your your consensus protocol
and so a priori you know it's a great
vision a priori from a theoretical
perspective it's not at all obvious
there should exist any
protocols that give you proofable
guarantees in the permissionless setting
okay
and that really from a technical
perspective you know you can view that
as sort of the key theorem if you like
uh in bitcoin that nakamoto came up with
figuring out how to do uh permissionless
consensus so that you get the kinds of
consistency and liveness guarantees that
we've been accustomed to ever since ever
since the 1980s
now my point on this slide is that you
know not only is the permissionless
consensus protocol design space not
empty but it also has sort of multiple
different looking inhabitants okay so i
want to i want to talk a little bit
about theory that we've been doing
trying to map out this design space of
permissionless consensus protocols so
let me just concretely give you two
examples of two protocols that look
quite different from each other
first one the original one bitcoin
i would say two big ideas okay so the
first idea is how are you going to
select a node to get this unilateral
sort of you know power to add the next
block to the blockchain okay so how do
you figure out which node is the next
block producer
to solve that problem you need something
known as a civil resistance mechanism
right so you basically need to make sure
that just you know you can't have
someone you know generating a million
sort of public keys for themselves and
tricking you into selecting them almost
all of the time
so you need some way to sort of you know
select a note at random with some
probability that they cannot easily
manipulate
the way that's done in bitcoin is what's
known as proof of work we don't really
need to know much about the details you
know if you've heard about hard crypto
puzzles that kind of stuff that's this
proof of work business point being is a
civil proof way of randomly selecting a
node to decide on the next block okay
that's the fundamental point
the second thing you need is some kind
of consensus protocol right given the
blocks that have been proposed to date
you need some sort of algorithm to tell
you which of those blocks are actually
finalized and in what order they should
be executed okay and so here also
famously in bitcoin there's the longest
chain protocol which says you know you
may have forks you may have different
blocks with a common predecessor don't
worry about it the longest chain is the
only one that matters okay so that's the
that's the consensus rule in bitcoin
now we now know very different looking
permissionless consensus protocols let
me highlight one i'm sure you're going
to hear more about on wednesday uh when
silvio speaks uh which is algorithm okay
but there's a bunch of other protocols
that have a from 30 thousand feet look
fairly similar
point being is just you it makes
if you look at the two big design
decisions in bitcoin al goran does both
of those steps differently it has civil
resistance random sampling but it does
it in a different way it does it not
based on proportional to computational
power but rather proportional to how
much stake in a native currency you have
locked up in a certain smart contract
okay that's the way they do civil
resistance and then consensus in
algorand and many other blockchain
protocols actually is not longest chain
consensus but rather is really kind of
um
you know basically builds on you know it
sort of stands on the shoulders of the
classic protocols from the 1980s and the
1990s which i'm going to call bft type
consensus okay again the details there
aren't so important i just want you to
know that there's multiple
permissionless consensus protocols and
they look quite different okay
in addition to these two examples
looking quite different operationally
they offer you quite you know fairly
different provable guarantees okay and
so the main thing i just want you to
focus on here for these mathematical
guarantees is that they're incomparable
okay
so when you're analyzing a consensus
protocol and a distributed system
you're kind of worried about adversaries
of two different types
first of all some of the nodes running
the protocol may be either buggy at best
or even a malicious actor trying to mess
up your protocol
so one kind of assumption you're going
to need is you're going to need some
lower bound on how many of the nodes
are running your protocol correctly okay
that's the first kind of assumption you
need
the second thing you're worried about is
the communication network okay and
you're worried about the possibility of
message delays i mean whether you know
uh um you know and how severe those can
be all right
and so the point is bitcoin is going to
be make a stronger assumption along one
axis and a weaker assumption along the
other axis okay so specifically
uh the good news about bitcoin is it is
it uh is well the bad news is that it
makes very strong assumptions about the
communication network it assumes that
there's an operatory known bound capital
delta every message that anybody ever
sends to anybody else is guaranteed to
arrive within delta time units okay so
it's really an appropriate model for
sort of normal operating conditions of a
network it's not appropriate when you
have network outages or now denial of
service attacks okay
the good news about bitcoin is it can
tolerate all it needs is a strict
majority of the nodes running the
protocol or more formally the
computational power running the protocol
and use a strict majority to be to be
running it correctly and then you
actually get provable liveness provable
consistency consistency just means all
the nodes stay in sync with each other
liveness just means that as long as
there's work to do the nodes keep doing
it okay
algorand meanwhile
one of its claims to fame is that uh
it's robust even under network attacks
and
and so um the formal definition is it
operates in the partially synchronous
model okay so this is the the sort of
standard deficit so this is you know um
from the 1980s the standard model that's
sort of a sweet spot between the
synchronous and the asynchronous models
which in particular is a good model for
denial of service attacks of unbounded
duration
so that's the good news weak assumptions
about the communication network the bad
news stronger assumptions about the
fraction of the nodes that are running
you're running the protocol correctly
okay it used to need to be 51
now it needs to be 67 percent
as usual as theoreticians right you see
multiple incomparable solutions you have
to ask you know for example can you get
the best the best of both worlds and if
not you know why not
more generally like i said i want to map
out this permissionless consensus
protocol design space right you have
these different protocols they look
different do they need to look different
you know are there different
mathematical properties driven
fundamentally by the different design
decisions or by something else so this
is sort of a series of works i've been
i've been um a collaboration with andy
lewis pai who's a professor at
london school of economics and so the
agenda of our work is to say let's start
from the mathematical properties you
want your blockchain protocol to have to
what extent does that dictate design
decisions you make along the way right
so does some mathematical property
dictate that you have to do civil
resistance using proof of work versus
proof of stake or consensus using
longest chain versus bft type something
like that to what extent of the
mathematical properties desired
force you into certain design decisions
okay
and um so the punch line here is you can
prove theorems along these lines so for
example um both of these are informal
i'll be a little bit more precise about
the first one in a second
but basically for example for algorand
and its property that it gets
consistency even under the presence of
network attacks even in the partially
synchronous model
it's required okay it's a necessary
condition that it uses proof-of-stake
civil resistance or something like it
it's a necessary condition that it uses
bft type consensus or something like it
in other words you could not have any
kind of you know variation or tweak on
bitcoin or any other longest chain
protocol or proof of work protocol that
captured the same guarantees that
algorand has it's really fundamentally
driven by both of the two design
decisions i told you okay
i know that's a little vague so let me
just a little bit more precise on that
first statement and then i'll just very
quickly talk a little bit about proof
systems
so
again this is work ongoing work with
andrew lewis pie
so you know we came up with a general
model we had to be agnostic to how you
were doing civil resistance how you're
doing consensus all that kind of stuff a
lot of details as you can imagine but
the part of the model i want to
highlight is this idea of a resource
pool
so we propose analyzing a blockchain
protocol in conjunction
with a resource pool which specifies
resource balances for all of the nodes
what's a resource balance that's
basically the amount of control over the
protocol's operation that that node has
for example and for a proof of work
blockchain your resource balance is
going to be your the amount of
computational power that you're bringing
to the protocol and a proof of stake
blockchain your resource balance is
going to be the amount of stake you have
locked up in some smart contract on the
chain in general abstractly the resource
balances just say how much power you
have over that protocol
there's a very important distinction
that we never actually define proof of
work or proof of stake in our work
that's like a little too operational for
our tastes but we have a notion of the
sized setting
which means
that your resource balance your control
over the protocol should just be
publicly visible given the state of the
blockchain given everything that's
happened in the past and if you think
about a proof of stake as an example of
a size setting because it's literally
just how much stake you have locked up
in a smart contract that lives on the
blockchain anybody can look and know
exactly everybody's resource balances
unsized setting means actually they
evolve independently and their proof of
work would be an example right if a
bunch of people turn off their machines
that's in no way reflected in the
blockchain state okay you have no idea
so unsized setting you should think of
as a proxy for proof of work
so that that first informal statement
that i gave that really sort of proof of
stake is essential for out for
algorand's guarantees here's the formal
statement in terms of an impossibility
result basically if you operate in the
unsized setting so if you're a
proof-of-work blockchain you really must
choose between some very basic minimal
liveness guarantee which you sort of
obviously want and consistency in the
partially synchronous setting in
particular right if you think of two as
kind of a hard constraint
then one and three you have to pick one
or the other
bitcoin picks the first one it does work
in the proof-of-work uh setting but it
gives up on consistency in the partially
synchronous setting
algorand uh makes a different choice
it is proof of stake it's not in the
unsized setting and it does get both
liveness and consistency in the
partially and the partially synchronous
setting so this is what i mean by proof
of stake or you know just generally
having some sized approach to resource
pools is absolutely fundamental to the
guarantees you get from algorand okay so
bitcoins bitcoin's reliance on proof of
work forces its compromises when you
have network attacks
very briefly third topic um just i can't
not say this given the audience
um you know if you study a little bit of
complexity theory
you study proof systems right and it's
hard to understate how deeply embedded
in the fabric of the of the sort of just
culture of theory computer science is
proof systems um you know and i'll i'll
defer to the people in the room who
actually sort of invented this concept
but but my understanding is that really
proof systems were sort of developed you
know so so by proof system i mean you
have approver you have a verifier a
conversation between them
my understanding is they're really
invented to basically sort of understand
the mysteries of the computational
universe right like what is a proof for
example
your first thought might be open up a
math book right there's a proof
that's sort of the np notion of a proof
right so think instead about a teacher
and a student having a conversation and
you want to know when does the student
left the way uh leave sort of having
learned some property right and that's
different there's interaction there's
potentially randomness and so that gave
us a proof system okay what really is a
proof in sort of the broad sense of the
term
uh as you all know this definition led
to many of the most famous theorems in
our field right zero knowledge for all
of the all of np the pcp theorem ip
equals pspace etc
uh amazingly with blockchains there are
now um multi-billion dollar startups
okay including ones founded by this
community members of this community
where what they are doing is practical
implementations of proof systems okay
i'm not i'd be curious if anyone
anticipated this happening back in the
mid 80s i'm guessing not but i'm not
totally sure but that is happening so
again 40 years ago
theorists captured something extremely
fundamental we are we all knew it was
fundamental right away it was sort of
obvious once you learn it i think but
you know not it's fundamental not just
in a purely intellectual sense but it's
actually exactly what you need for
blockchains to reach their their full
capabilities
so i'm just going to say tiny bit about
that just so so you understand what i
mean
it's about scaling it's about making the
computer in the sky more powerful okay i
told you it's very weak you know maybe
15 transactions per second it's like
it's from the 1970s how do you at least
get it up to like the 1990s or something
like that
one approach is to graft in additional
computation from outside the blockchain
okay typically this would be a third
party but even just imagine like imagine
you've got ethereum you've got someone
who's like a really big fan of ethereum
and they happen to have this like super
powerful computer
and they're like yeah ethereum let me
help you out a little bit let me take
some of the load off of your shoulders
okay i'll do some transaction processing
i can do 10 000 transactions per second
no problem and i'll just kind of give
you periodic updates i'll give you like
an fyi hey i processed all these
transactions here's the state diff okay
so here's the new state of the virtual
machine given the computation that i did
and why would you do that well now right
this should be a pareto improvement over
the current situation current situation
is basically if you want to use ethereum
you have to send it to the sort of very
um to this computer where computation is
very scarce and therefore very abundant
sorry very cheap but here you're gonna
have a second option to send it to this
off chain computer where computation is
abundant and therefore should be cheap
now if you think about it for this to
work uh these periodic updates better be
verifiable okay by the ethereum
blockchain by the computer in the sky
otherwise this you know so-called fan of
ethereum might just say hey you know i
did all these transactions uh you know
in the new state it just so happens that
i own all the coins right and that's not
okay right so ethereum needs to be able
to verify okay that the resulting states
that the off chain computer allegedly
computed actually is correct okay so
they need to be periodic verifiable
updates
and there's a specific type of proof
system
which again was studied you know way
before blockchains 15 years before
blockchains at least
known as snarks which is exactly the
construct you need exactly what is
needed to make this idea work okay
it's a specific type of proof system
again there's many people in this room
that know much more about this than me
but let me just you know for those of
you that are wondering what's the
acronym about uh so the s is for
succinct
this is kind of uh you know for this you
know off-chain computer to take any load
off of ethereum's shoulders it better be
the case that you know the amount of
work ethereum has to do to verify the
proof of correctness is less than
redoing all of the work from scratch
okay so that's basically what the what
the role this the succinct plays
you know i talked about proof systems as
being interactive the teacher and the
student
you know permissionless blockchains
right nodes can just sort of go down you
know disappear forever so you don't want
to you don't want to assume that the
people who came up with the proof a long
time ago are still available online so
you really want non-interactive proofs
you just want a single proof that's
posted once and for all to the
blockchain everybody can read for the
rest of for the rest of time
argument is just sort of basically proof
basically it should be should be
verifiable so you can correctly prove if
you did do the computations correctly
and you can't prove uh if you didn't do
them correctly
uh knowledge this is also important in
the blockchain context but actually not
quite as important as the first three
okay so the first three are really
totally essential for this grafting and
off-chain computation idea uh to to make
sense okay
and so last slide and then i'll wrap up
um final thing i want to say is you know
initially in the early days of proof
systems right the focus my understanding
is really on kind of you know the
structural complexity aspects but i p
equals p space sort of understanding the
relationships between various classes
once that's been sort of mapped out it's
natural to look at a more fine-grained
approach okay to actually sort of study
various resources you might want to
minimize and ask exactly how many
resources are necessary to prove various
types of statements okay and this work
has been going on solid for for my whole
career basically
and um maybe no surprise but it's still
like just amazing for me to see this if
you look at the metrics that theorists
sort of focused on just because they
seem like the obvious natural ones to
focus on like you know verifier time
proof lengths and approver time those
are literally exactly the metrics that
need to be minimized for this whole
snark thing to really take blockchains
to the next um to the next level of
power okay so length of the proof that's
going to correspond oh so the one i hope
it was clear but as far as the analogy
the
the big computer in the sky this is the
verifier in the proof system sense right
this is the party that has less
knowledge and or less computation and
then the off chain computer is the
approver that's the one with more uh
computation and or more information okay
and so with that in mind right so the
length of the proof which is something
you know we've always
tried to minimize um that corresponds to
footprints on this sort of big computer
in the sky where where storage is scarce
and therefore expensive
similarly verification time that's
computation done by the virtual machine
the ethereum virtual machine the
computer in the sky which is also very
expensive
prover time this is what people are now
working really hard to sort of minimize
as much as possible um because this is
really what's going to limit sort of
exactly how many transactions that off
chain computer can offload from ethereum
right if it takes you know end to the 10
time to generate the proof it's not
going to be able to generate a proof for
that many transactions okay so getting
this proven time small you know we'll
see like it's getting better and better
and better and ultimately if it gets
small enough this literally will be the
the road map that wins for the scaling
of blockchains okay
so let me wrap up here just you know the
main point think of a blockchain it's a
general purpose computer in the sky it's
open access anyone can use it um it's
ownerless or operator
operatorless in effect meaning it's run
by this consensus protocol across many
different nodes it enables the
enforcement of property rights for
digital data that lives on that computer
and there's lots and lots of interesting
computer science and specifically
theoretical computer science that's
absolutely essential for it to realize
its full potential let me stop there
thanks
[Applause]
all right thanks very much tim
i'm just about the
excuse me impossibility result
um
uh is it clear that there's always
something
negative about the uh what you call the
unsized
setting uh is it for instance um
required that there's an energy
consumption cost associated with that
okay good question yeah so that's a
related question so
again in our model we don't define proof
of work per se um we just define unsized
which basically means you can't
automatically deduce the resource
balances from the on-chain information
if you want to talk specifically about
proof-of-work
um energy consumption may well be
fundamental to the proof-of-work
approach to civil resistance there's no
real
you know
i mean people have tried to have
versions of proof of work that are less
energy consumptive but really the road
forward there simply looks like proof of
stake blockchains and other alternative
civil resistance mechanisms
um
oh yeah thanks i learned a lot about i
mean of course i see all the stuff in
the news i don't really know how it
works i learned a lot today um one thing
that i guess really caught my attention
as you mentioned
bitcoin makes this assumption that
you know more than 50 of the cpu power
running the protocol is honest
and i'm curious you know like i think
the value of all bitcoin in the world
combined is less than a trillion dollars
which is like not that it's a lot for me
but it's you know much less than
the budget of the us government for
example or put together a few senate
billionaires um
is is there i mean is that a risk that
you know bitcoin could be over if some
some government decides one day to just
like take over the
i mean does one government have enough
power for example or like budget to just
take over bitcoin
right so it's a good question so it's a
question about basically 51 attacks so
really you know so
it's kind of a question of like how real
is this you know when i say it sort of
has no owner or operator with much
control over it to what extent is that
actually true
right so that which is an important
question
um and like an extreme failure mode
would be if a single actor took sort of
single-handed unilateral control over
the blockchain for example for bitcoin
by acquiring 51 of its hashrate
um so the first question is just like
you know
so a couple of things i mean so um
certainly uh when you're designing
blockchain protocols you want to think
about those issues and you want to think
about ways to make attacks on it as
expensive as possible
um
separately you also want to think about
kind of you know recovery plans in the
event of a 51 attack right sort of fun
right because like if someone took over
bitcoin and started sort of you know
fork didn't had all these new blocks i
mean everybody would be i mean be in
plain view everyone would sort of know
that that happened right now if you just
go the code is law root and literally
just follow the protocol then in some
sense there's nothing anybody can do
right this is the new longest chain
there's nothing you can do about it but
in reality you're right these protocols
kind of exist in this broader social
context right and if there is some
reason for everybody who is sort of
running the old bitcoin nodes to kind of
say like oh no let's just sort of
upgrade the protocol have a different
version like we'll call the new version
like bitcoin prime or something
then it's just about convincing vendors
that they should pay attention to the
record on bitcoin prime rather than on
the original bitcoin which had been
taken over
so it's hard it's hard to see how to do
theory about that but the point is sort
of like failures at the consensus layer
kind of escalate up to the social layer
where if you have sort of enough norms
around what to do in the face of an
attack
uh you know it's not
it's it's certainly not obviously an
existential threat put it that way it
would be very disruptive right for
someone to to someone to take it over
and needing to kind of fork off a
different version
but you know it is something one could
do so
hi first of all thank you very much for
this talk i had a question marina came
up with an answer i'll ask it anyway
maybe we will have a different answer
how important is the end in snarks i
mean if you want to have this offline
off-chain very um
cpu that runs this offload takes this um
of the shoulders of the chain
so how important is it that it would be
non-interactive maybe you can do better
things if you let it
do interactive stuff no that's a great
question the question was about how
essential is non-interactivity really i
would say for the original like bitcoin
ethereum vision it's pretty important we
really just had in mind 50 years later
someone could sort of download some
software read the last 50 years of the
blockchain and then just sort of catch
up and sort of go from there
because again who are you going to
interact with for some post for some
proof that was posted 40 years ago
but there's no question especially and
this is now maybe more at the
application layer than the consensus
layer but definitely there are
situations
you know these are these i don't know
that any of this is his production
there's certainly groups experimenting
with this idea of doing a modest amount
of interaction so basically making more
assumptions about how long people are
online
in order to accomplish sort of something
better
um so absolutely i mean uh
you know i don't know like i said i
don't know that limited i don't know the
interaction's gonna be
ever a thing at the consensus layer that
we talked about but in the space broadly
it's definitely important yeah
um
how
much everything tree realizes if you
were willing to live in the permissioned
consensus world so suppose you wanted to
generate a blockchain but where you have
10 parties where you maybe trust
all for liveness but a majority for
safety for correctness or something like
that and and there are known parties you
know some non-government uh whatever
is everything trivial and everything
solved in that setting or is it still
interesting well it depends on
everything i mean i mean what the main
thing you do is the 51 attack issue goes
away i would say but you just you just
no longer worry about that right
um so at best
you trivialize what's happening in the
consensus layer right but there's this
big stack of things going on right so
there's still the stuff about like how
do you scale up the basic consensus
layer but it doesn't help you with that
well it might help you but it doesn't
trivialize that problem there's also
just all of the questions of the
application layer it really doesn't
trivialize any of those problems either
um i mean the main thing
the main sort of trade-off that people
are are playing with i'm very curious to
see how this plays out it's one thing
that's actually super fun about the
space is even though i've now kind of
thought a lot about a lot of aspects
there are so many things that i have no
idea how they're going to play out over
the next five years it's just really
interesting and so um
right so one so one of the reasons you
only get the 15 transactions per second
is because you have
tons of nodes it's very globally
distributed
and so the main thing if you sort of
have fewer nodes independent of whether
or not you sort of know who they are but
if you just have like a more tightly
coupled network of 30 nodes you can just
do way more processing because there's
just way less coordination required
so if these things really go mainstream
will it be with kind of a scaled up
version of ethereum like i discussed or
will it be with more like an
architecture that uses kind of a small
tightly knit set of maybe you know
partially permissioned nodes or
something like that and definitely there
are groups exploring all these different
parts of the trade-offs and we're just
going to have to see what happens so
all right we'll stop it there
uh join me in thanking tim again for a
fantastic
[Applause]